I think uh in order to be an outstanding
recruiter in this market you need to be
surprisingly different how do you make
sure you're surprisingly different I
think that starts with Integrity I think
Integrity is the number one thing we
look at when we hire people I always
tell my team to try to give the best
possible advice to candidates and
clients especially when it's not in your
own best interest because that's where
you you'll really make a lasting
impression but if I'd add to next to
Integrity it would be authenticity in
order to be able to create a a good
connection really fast which I I think
is crucial and curiosity like as a
recruiter you need to be great at asking
questions I add that one to the list as
well